you have to hurry where's my car I
didn't like the color let's get a new
one what no Jessie I need them my
briefcase was in that car I'll take you
shopping it's a [ __ ] briefcase
yeah I think so we have to get to my
briefcase then we find Beth Wilder why
who is she she knows about the fracture
I trust her glad you trusted somebody
it's not that simple jack
they can't secrets of news you're safe
safe look around you will does this feel
safe to you this is my fault
it won't be this would happen did
everything in my power to stop it but
you never told me any of this
I couldn't just how long have you known
we don't have time for this now Jack we
have to get to that briefcase
let's move for more of them show up
Jack
Oh Jack gotta go hold on sorry jack
Paul what happened to you what are you
doing only what's necessary
think about this you don't know it's at
stake I know exactly what's at stake
that's why I'm here you believe you can
stop what's coming I'm giving you one
chance to change your mind
this path it's already said it can't be
changed the past the future I've seen
I've lived it for 17 years 17 years it
was you
the first experiment come with me and we
can see this through or hold onto your
hope and burn with it now listen I built
the device I can stop this I can't you
can't madness there's no harm in trying
there is that's why I can't risk you
opposing me will it doesn't have to win
like this we can't just let this happen
I'll never stop trying it took me years
to come to terms of what must be done
but we don't have years wait wait wait
trigger I never wanted this